okay today we're looking at the efforts
of Karen we're only spending one class
session but it's kind of a shame because
it is a important wall theory why we can
only pack in so much during the semester
so we are looking at the Virginia held
article feminist transformations of
theory and you notice that we're already
using some some different language I'm
talking about the ethics of care
primarily as a moral theory and then she
is talking about feminist
transformations of all theory and you
might say are these the same thing that
exactly the same thing feminist ethics
and ethics of care overlap to a large
extent but they're not identical but
they're not completely detached from
each other either the ethics of care as
we know it is a recent moral theory it's
not saying some things that are
completely radically new as a matter of
fact you might actually as we're going
through this say yeah didn't so-and-so
talk about this didn't we cover this
just two weeks ago with another in the
world theorist and that's true but
putting it all together the same same
big big bash is something you know think
about recipes for example you can do
just about anything you want to pizza
and stove these days
there's some dishes that unless you put
all the components together they're not
what they are and so think about Chile
for example you can have a Chile without
me - it will take tofu to put that in
there I suppose you could have Chile
without beans
what do you absolutely have to have
Chile for it to each other a couple
things right yeah
and you might cut it with water or wine
or bullion or or whatever you want but
it's got to be tomato base what else
even more essential it's not chilly
unless it's got an X yeah Jessi bummer
yeah the Chile plummet is a mix of a
bunch of spices to ground chilies the
Cayenne cumin oregano salt pepper and
unless unless it he has that in it it's
not Chile it might be a goulash or
something else anything else gets the
other Chile I was not really chilly
imagine somebody like that some sort of
pepper either peppers and onions or
something otherwise what else have you
got I just got Tomatoes maybe some beans
and chili but that's don't think well
they're gonna be others who care like
that there's all these different themes
that are incorporated into it and if you
took some of them out it wouldn't be the
ethics of carrying it would be something
different the biggest one is really this
woman's concerns and experiences that's
why the ethics of care is tied together
with feminist ethics because talking
about relationships as important didn't
we talk about that with Ross just two
weeks ago yeah and every time I asked
you in last
what's it good for you you got to bring
up family and friends you bring up
relationships motions we talked about
emotions sometimes talent waxes if
nobody's ever recognized emotions before
we know that's not the case
Plato talked about the emotions you're
gonna see Aristotle talking about great
- Bentham and mill did very much
but real persons over abstract
principles again we just talked about
that with Ross wasn't that particle you
guys if I'm so attractive about his
moral theory as opposed to come when I
asked you about in class so when you
brought that up and said yeah I can
relate to this this actually has to do
with real-life ordinary people the kind
of morality that were raised but this is
really focused on women's concerns and
experiences and specifically
childbearing mothering nurturing and
support so let's start out with with a
feminist ethics and there's a couple
things I want to put on the table first
of all what does it mean is to say that
something is feminist we've almost and
presumably some of the other feminists
some sense of the term and you've heard
about it or read about it in classes and
magazines you know TV shows who knows
what else
what does it mean to be a feminist may
have somebody asked me are you a
feminist I'm always a little suspicious
of guys who call themselves feminists in
part because of my generation where a
lot of the guys who did that were just
sort of like trying to get you know get
into women maybe that's not the case for
for guys in the class and if you tell me
feminist means this thing then I might
say yeah I can get
yeah I guess I'm a FEMINIST if you say
it's this thing then maybe I say yeah I
can't go along down so what does it
actually mean what does it mean to you
you guys but we have a whole class of
women presumably have some you know
ideas it's okay if you have different
ideas about this too because it's hard
to pin down what this means
so what does it mean to you guys
are you guys
in some sense of the term would you be
comfortable calling yourself of what do
you think even if you're not a feminist
you have some ideas for things right
okay so women's rights and that by
itself is already something that has
changed in its meeting over time so what
do you think the sort of beginning
rights were in fact your history books
yeah yeah they the right to actually
participate in political life to choose
who's going to be in charge you know in
France me that women didn't actually get
the right to vote until the nineteen
fifties when I think about the
friendship being so much more advanced
than us they didn't get the right to
vote until halfway through the century
so the right to vote that's a big one
that's political
they know this classroom just two
generations ago you wouldn't have been
called women students that have been
calling them Colette's
which is kind of a weird thing to say
why would they call you that
well because that would mean that Maris
was in a co-educational University which
was unusual that was you know something
that was changing the ranks of Education
any wanted you to major in anything you
want right can anyone tell you not to is
your they do they've got grounds for
what lawsuit right because those are
certainly rights or rights to education
what are other women's rights in that
matter got political rights educational
rights yeah the right to work in in any
field right so you can't be excluded
from certain jobs or confined to nurse
teacher seventy very good of things yeah
it can't be confined to those fields as
a matter of fact there's more women in
college unemployment higher
in part because of the choice of
profession and part two more women
finish your job success we're about to
get paid less this is because you're one
with anything occurred even these things
we thought was a big issue wasn't just
two generations ago even the generation
ago interestingly I don't know about the
stance for your generation for my
generation the wage gap has actually
shifted the other way so it women make
slightly more than men but in the
previous generations there's a big
there's a big difference women make less
than that for sometimes for doing the
same job so you've got all these four
different areas any other important
areas of rights
yeah
now then I'm going to talk about these
as reproductive rights because these
have to do with I'm Tina Mariko and for
a long time women were sort of pushed
out of the educational political all
these scooters and just into the home
and regarded as you know just there to
cook clean and reproduce having having
control over reproductive rights helps
to break that so so feminism is about
those about getting grants or protecting
you because you've read about or is it
about anything else
when I think of feminism I think of like
an extreme like it's very like they I
mean I don't think that's what it is by
definition but I feel like a lot of
people associate feminism with a very
yeah extreme way of looking at we know
if there's a distinction that gets made
sometimes between equality feminism and
gender covers and there's a lot of other
ways in which people make this
distinction and I think what you're
talking about there fits under what they
call gender feminism where on the one
hand there's this sense of historical
injustice and they want to turn the
tables and I've always been oppressing
women
and my nature oppressed women you know
you've all heard this this before right
women should be in charge of everything
everything is always better when women
are in charge and then there's a quality
photos of the focus on you know people
rights equal treatment as people
opportunities that's earth and they seem
to be quite different from each other
and I don't want it like myself I can
get behind and equal rights thing
because to me that actually seems if I'm
a good plate mister include Aristotelian
and women are equal to men and
importantly efficient people have met
another important ways I can't myself
get behind each other photos and
departments you need to do someone that
but I think you can find a woman I do
part-time I guess probably similar to
what he wants to block all the because
they're all rapists oppressors well you
know this what is this this whole
spectrum right feminists athletes to
meet a lot of different things one of
the things that I think is important to
keep in mind as you're reading this
Virginia House article when was it
written you guys any of you look at the
data before most of you were born
yeah very good 1990 so an entire
generation ago so that was written as I
was just entering college myself that's
pressure do you think that any of the
stuff that she's saying might have
gotten a bit dated you know so let me
ask you because you're all this
generation of currently 20 year olds or
21 year olds 22 year olds do you think
you have the same experiences the
previous generation generation my
generation some of the same experiences
alright what's the same thing
how many see yourself actually got a
lion
walk your partner or being married maybe
raising children
that's pretty similar to background
right raising children more or less the
same as it used to be except you know
everything we have nicer materials
what's changed from saving your your
father's of your grandmother's
generations experience - yeah I think
our generation is getting a very cleaner
and children they are having challenges
protecting children first yeah I think
you're right about that
I wonder how much of that has to do with
thought they had the economy has to you
know I wouldn't want to be entering
workplace
it was tough enough that my generation
is gonna be the previous generations
haven't done a very good job of keeping
things going well for you we different
ethical issues there any other ways in
so some waiting a little bit longer to
get involved in these activities of
human beings that's interesting to say
nothing is expected yeah nothing is
expected of you yes
twenty-five Americans with them it's
kind of so if you don't have kids by the
time you're 25 you're not going to feel
that whereas say your grandmother might
have felt some pressure I think you're
right it makes a lot of sense so when we
were reading through this this piece
women's constraints and experiences
that's something that's going to be
changing over time and in society there
are certain constants though some of
your in the fashion right
what's women's fashion like compared to
men's fashion would you say it changes a
lot more it poses more burdens on
yeah yeah I mean if you get women's
magazines
everything changes once a year
completely one year everything should be
orange the next year everything should
be pastels and you know the lengths of
things change
I bought this jacket back in 1991 I can
wear this provided I'll gain too much
weight I can wear this the rest of my
life unless we go through the 70s again
in men's fashion you know suddenly
changes a lot now you know my there's
certain places I can't go and be seen as
yeah if I wear something like this but
well they're pretty you know relatively
rare but what about women's fashion you
know women's fashion there's a lot more
demands aren't there and it's been that
way for a long time and that's one area
that hasn't changed that went to an area
of concern or experience interested that
we think about feminist ethics so that's
a long introduction let's let's look now
at what is the ethics of care so
Virginia health she starts out with this
this central question can can moral
theory the sort of stuff that we've been
studying this semester can that just
take into account these things without
changing so for example relationships as
good it's a lot of you brought this up
over the course of the semester I would
ask you what do you consider to be good
things what gives your life meaning you
would say things like my friendships my
family or I think it's
children can be made part of ethics
without really changing an awful lot
probably right we have talked about that
in our class could we talk you know for
instance about content parenting you
know is it alright for a parent to make
their child go to the college that they
went to because the relationship
probably certainly a virtue ethics
perspective what about the emotions can
we say that the emotions ought to be
involved in reason well there it gets a
little trickier if you're calm
absolutely not right and we talked about
this your comment you don't want those
emotions and desire is getting in there
and skewing your reasoning and making
you think you're doing the right thing
when you're actually not going right
back or if you're bentham right we're
all kind of self-centered if we were
utilitarians we're going to get away
from that being self-centered and start
looking at things very rationally but
you know does everybody have to be down
emotions I think of my virtue on face
some of it some of the emotions captain
press but but not hold some of them are
valuable real persons over abstract
principles I kept in Ross incorporate
that you certain operations together
Aristotle times less what about this
stuff can this be taken into and to
account without radically changing from
all theory maybe not maybe that's the
real sticking point women's concerns and
experiences because if you look at the
history of all theory Howell is right it
has to been done that women does that
necessarily mean it's auntie woman or
you know suppressive women or things
like that not necessarily but you know
what's your experience when you get
together with a bunch of people and
decide let's say planning apart what
music should we listen to and all of you
like listening to a certain kind of
music you actually been proposed now
let's listen to this other stuff instead
you might get something out of this no
well how discriminatory of you you know
if men have been making the moral theory
throughout the ages and a lot of these
were men who didn't have an awful lot of
involvement with you know some of them
were were confirmed bachelors the house
that was it or some of them lived in a
society where gender roles were very
distinct and a Plato Aristotle lived in
the Athens
on ancient Athens but men were in the
marketplace and the polis and women were
in the home and Athens was probably the
most separate Society that like Sparta
was not quite so this party had its own
problems if you've got this for the
situation are men going to take
seriously women's concerns and
experiences probably not wouldn't you
have the same problem if you're thinking
about different cultures or races or
classes or anything like that probably
right or I think about you you guys have
young people every four years that'd
make a great appeal to you
you know vote you know this election you
might be the deciding factor and then
the last elections you're done young
people actually manage quite a bit they
put Obama over the top a lot of places
do you think that the older people and
the politicians really know much about
you or care much about your perspective
or are you know hankering to make things
work for you you feel that way no you
feel the opposite way yeah you know this
is a pretty endemic thing this is thing
so how is putting out that if we're
going to change moral theory to try to
make it more inclusive to try to take
into account things that have left out
and make it better than well theories
result there's probably going to take
some big changes that's going to take
what she calls a radical transformation
and I think part of the reason why you
as a generation don't feel in the same
place as your parents brand here
grandparents is because some of those
changes have already been made so she is
proposing some things that have already
been done but you know if you look at
the field of philosophy of it any better
looked into being philosophers right now
hustle in the United States only about
17% women there's a lot of the women who
are actually doing philosophy not a
philosophy department certainly Studies
departments or English departments or
history departments report with science
departments but the field would suffice
to a largely male-dominated health talks
about a couple different things that
would have to change the first thing she
talks about emotions yeah talks about
moral theory Cueto often as opposing
reason and emotion so you come into an
ethics class and you learn about the
toilet area know something you learn
about the ontology and when you're going
to apply them somebody says to you put
your feelings aside this has nothing to
do with you you need to think about
things abstractly you know take yourself
out of the situation if you're in
utilitarian you don't count your
pleasure your designers is worth any
more than anybody else's or parecon
Chien don't trust your desires
nobody goes if you're utilitarian part
of what makes utilitarians you you get
past the penny dealers perspective where
your own desires actually do matter more
than other people's because they're your
desires and you put them on the same
level of services no that doesn't
necessarily have to exclude other
people's feelings
I mean Terry and I think pretty deeply
about this then I could say well her
feelings are just as important as his
feelings as my feelings as your feelings
but utilitarians don't you two talk
about that instead they they talk about
abstract crystals what about our
emotions let me put it to you like this
when you are thinking about right and
wrong
do you feel anything when you're
thinking about situations concrete
situations where you've seen so they do
the right thing or do the wrong thing do
you feel affected emotionally when you
see when you watch a movie you see
somebody do a generous action or you see
something sacrifice himself or another
person or you're watching movies see the
bad guy
don't want beating and kicking at
pencils do you feel emotion do you think
those emotions are in some way a good
guy - whether things are right or wrong
I see a lot of nodding heads why do you
think that they're a good guy
okay I think that's I think that's a
good point
we you're right need we have less
control over whether we feel our
emotions spontaneously we often feel
angry what do you
yeah yeah a sense of sadness or greed
that's through this kind of
interchangeable fingers right and go
from being sad that suddenly you
realized how injustice isn't now you're
angry and after you're done being angry
fuel say that again anything else do you
feel when you see somebody doing
something wrong anxious yeah the sense
of anxiety or fear and maybe because it
could happen to you or could happen to
those of you you care about it alone
yeah that's interesting yeah especially
the more connected you are to that
person if they're a friend of yours if
they're a family member in some cases
discussed like that discussed as a
normal human emotion matter of fact yes
families like categories of
facial features they're not the features
of expressions and you can recognize
emotions across cultures so you can look
at it than the angry face and this is
this culture over here and it looks like
an angry face and you can tell surprised
you can tell it's just there's a certain
basic range of emotions yeah are we
always right with these do we always
feel anger towards the right people in
the right situations no but there are
cases where we probably should feel
angry what about more positive emotions
are there other things that we can call
the world emotions because they they're
good they lead us to do good things or
to recognize the goodness of other
people in situations what do you feel
when somebody does something good
yeah break the sense of gratitude that's
that's an emotion it's not just a thing
Roset we don't care if you feel the
emotion we're only really interested if
you do the actions right but isn't it
more important so they actually feels
grateful and you can tell that they feel
grateful if somebody says it somebody
sends a thank-you note to you and it's
very nicely pen but you know they don't
care for you that makes sense yeah it's
not quite the same thing as happiness or
joy yes it's kind of a sense of
contentment okay from the rest when you
relate to that it's hard it is hard to
give it a name notice that you've
experienced
admiration sometimes you feel for people
that do good things what about love
again every time I asked you you know
what are the good things that like to
grab your friends and your family and
presumably you feel some affection some
walk towards them right not just desire
to get something from them not just
happy that they they make you actually
feel something towards them
you also care about here your concern
what we call that in the world emotional
what about when you see bad things
happening to people who don't deserve
them or actually good does that bother
you that give you a sense of pain
Aristotle calls that pity that's that's
what pity means it's feeling a feeling
bothered by seeing somebody else's
distress compassion empathy these are
all the words that we use ethics of care
says those are really important those
emotions that they should not only be
responses that we base on reasoning on
but they should actually go into our
reasoning so we shouldn't just be these
cold detached utilitarian or content
beings that no here's the right thing
we're going to put it in this box we
should actually feel a certain way
that's part of what the ethics of Karen
is putting forth and they're saying that
this is often been left out of more
theory and maybe you as you've been you
know studying these things a semester
maybe you thought this was missing too
when you when we get to Aristotle you
see it isn't actually missing in all
cases
militaries what else relationships are
what are the important relationships for
you right now is a you know early
twenties college what helps anchor you
and tell you who you are
yeah
friends yeah that's probably very
important for you at this this age
family yeah so what is what's family
comprise what is it how'd you get here
first on somebody get into like you know
yeah at least one night together yeah
yeah
mother father was biologically man what
kind of family here in a blended family
together I actually have like two by
actually two two fathers but I don't
know I have a adoptive mother and birth
mother my adoptive mother's death this
was a long time ago but I have such a
parents but actually in the household
that I grew up in uncles have answered
about as close as parents cousins were
about as close as brothers and sisters
okay this gigantic Larry's family clan
and we get together every every year for
about three days so my first cousins are
sorta like brothers and sisters
and my my more distant cousins are like
other people's first cousins it makes it
a little bit claustrophobic sorry pester
people that you bring into the family
they don't always like it but then
angers me that tells me who I am all
those memories I am a demon with my mom
and dad but my cousins and doing things
and I think for most of you those
relationships are very important as well
they tell you who you are even if you're
at the stage right now where you're
reacting against mom and dad I'm never
going to be like that they're horrible
there's a lot more of that in here than
you than you realize kids someday you'll
find yourself repeating their behaviors
mannerisms and lines of moral reasoning
right and that's from the standpoint of
ethics of care that's not necessarily a
bad thing you would want to thank you
let's say the parents were real jerks
and abusive you don't want to continue
that but what is it or not what if they
actually do produce that that thing that
we still haven't given a name to the
sense of global contentment maybe what
do they actively work to do that well
hopefully you'll do that the urges or
with whoever did whoever else it is that
you have relationship friends
relationships between friends have will
often have been looked at in one theory
as getting in the way you know if I'm
the utilitarian I'm supposed to look at
my pleasure as being only worth as much
as everybody else's right
what if I'm friends with her aren't I
getting have a natural tendency to
veiling her pleasure and
trying to wake her paying more than
somebody else's that would make me no
longer an impartial right so maybe
friendships aren't such a good thing
from that perspective
well the ethics of care says that
relationships are among the most
important goods that exist and
relationships aren't just sort of
contractual connection between people I
give you something you give me something
there are things that we find ourselves
in and we can't necessarily change the
nature of their relationship or make it
be just whatever we want you don't know
that expression you can pick your
friends but you can't pick your
relatives rather true it means your
marriage I suppose but there's also
something good about that your mom and
dad are always going to be your mom and
dad are they probably if you have
screwed up at certain points in your
life and you were really anxious about
you know respect you love you who that
sort of thing and you know hopefully if
they were good parents that came to you
and they said I really don't like what
you did but I still love you're still
like my son my daughter how's that
that's a good then they actually have
allowed you to become the person that
you are today being given that kind of
support
so the evidence of care says that's
really central relationships are not
just reducible to what the people are
getting out of them they're something
within which people find themselves and
for the evidence of care one of the most
important relationships that's been an
often downplay or left out is the
relationship between mother and child
because you know if you're only focused
on what happens at the marketplace or in
the political life or in the library or
in the university and there aren't a lot
of women there at that time then women's
concerns and experiences like the
relationship between mother and child
which is absolutely critical for the
development of a person
those get left out they just get sort of
assumed or taken for granted but if you
want to psychologists Caucasus if you
want to know something about why people
look at their parents look at how their
their relationship with them and their
parents works that's part of what made
them who they are
real persons over abstract principles
this is also a part of the ethics of
care you often get the idea in an ethics
class that we're not talking about real
people to protect all these sort of
general examples all these these
principles that then somehow you have to
figure out how to fit into your life I
think the kind of assignments that I
give you hopefully help you to see how I
connect these to your own life but it's
still a lot of work as the ethics of
care says that what's really important a
person's principles are you know you
don't have to throw them away but
persons are a really matter your clutter
thing or your your sense of self-worth
your development as a person that's what
really counts and if principles help us
understand that that's great but really
we'll be able to focus on our heart the
connections between us
again you know if you think about
carotene relationships especially the
relationship between mother and child
that would of all of this is how to
understand the the cell and the person
and this is really central that that's
too because who's them
who does good or bad things you know
some abstract person out there we use it
as an example blow the conch in its
office right we did the contestants who
I am but they've also made other people
for better or worse who they are each
one of you I think can say the same not
as many good or bad things at this point
but when you're my age you'll be able to
say that but back out hopefully more
good things and bad things don't
certainly hopefully hopefully work with
things that I've done so how should we
understand the human self what kind of
model are already used so each each
moral theory that we're studying has
some sort of a bottle with a stoicism
before stoicism you were really a ruling
principle this is this reflective thing
and your emotions really weren't part of
whether they are kind of things that got
in the way
that led you away from even with Plato
I think you know played over that three
part Sol the bottom part of your
emotions and desires and things like
that except for the emotion
you know which is you know sort of a
higher point but the better the best
part of you is just reason it didn't
really have any emotion that's involved
pets and designers to be rational but
that was above it the play don't talk
about your relationships with other
people very much Epictetus still a
little bit roles but there it's just a
matter of doing the right thing what do
you feel like doing well there are a lot
of models of the self the end
traditional ethics that haven't really
addressed some of these things
another thing that held the points out
with the traditional concept of the self
we often look at it okay here's my
individual self over here I have my
desires and my feelings of my
relationships in my personal history and
then there's the universal self or
society over here and that's everybody
and so either I satisfy my desires or
take care of myself or I'm taking care
of everyone so either either I'm an
egoist or I'm a utilitarian either i
satisfy my desires and inclinations or
like contests
I'm following the dictates of duty which
are those things that everybody should
do right universalize what about the
middle stuff in here it sounds almost
like that's all you've got is a society
and then the individual and there's
nothing in between but is there
something
there's there's something in between for
you isn't there
what's in between yeah hold network of
people right you've been introduced to
some of the people that you have
relationships with by other people that
you have relationships with who maybe
not you actually for that so you've got
this entire batch or network a very
contingent relationships that didn't
have to happen you know the one guy that
I'm still best friends with from high
school actually one of the few people
actually I kept in touch with before
Facebook came about from high school
and I met him through another friend who
that later died and yeah I mean you
can't predict this or feel these
networks of friends well what else is in
between universal society and you as an
animistic individual totally on your own
no connection static vales
by your family your whole family maybe
you didn't think of that your friends
with your family with family and friends
are hard to state directly they overlap
to some degree but they're not exactly
the same yeah can you just do whatever
you want
you know this animistic totally egoist
individual can you do anything you like
anytime you want to if you want to
maintain this network of relationships
well all your emotions I like flee so
that people yep it's that if you go up
what do you wanna do you're gonna have
that feeling bad their sad thing yeah
they actually make them feel bad yeah
screw you I don't I go fishing I hate
fishing
you're stupid somebody could make
sufficient they're not gonna like that
and then they're not going to go fishing
anymore and I ask you to do anything
else yeah you're right if you if you
behave in an egoistic way and you don't
recognize the goodness of relationships
the importance of maintaining
relationships then you will have you
know isolated individual you won't be a
happy person and you can't just reduce
all those relationships to abstract
rules of fairness or justice or things
like that neither can you you have to
treat each individual as an individual
as connected to you in that relationship
as if there are emotion it's not just
their rationality but their emotions man
especially if you're dealing with
children to our very emotional she also
talks about concern and sympathy when
you feel concern and sympathy do you
feel concerned in sympathy for Humanity
in general any do feel that I know is
from humanity the whole world is
suffering does that I do feel concern or
sympathy how do you
yeah so somebody or some group that you
can point to right they're real they
they have particular qualities they have
a history a narrative yeah you're right
when we feel concern for each other we
feel concern for each other if we're
actually feeling concerned as persons
not just as standards for some sort of
principle so I think back to what our
talking about consciousness
you know kingdom Tibetans that would be
very different from this wasn't that if
I'm looking at you and in a conscient
way I'm not really looking at you as we
use the word person but I'm not really
looking at you so much as a real person
you know age such-and-such my students
here in this Merrick class with his or
her own background and strengths and
weaknesses and feelings about things all
that we could put to the side of the
couch in perspective what matters the
fact that you're you're free you're
capable of choosing your own ass that's
not very much ism that's not you
you're not the caption subject are you
if you are we should talk after class
but I'd like to know a few things more
about the conscious substance but what
you're not and either in line we're real
people and when we feel concerned or
sympathy or you know care when we care
we're doing it towards the particular
real people within the matrix of
relationships so if you have to sum up
the ethics of care very briefly one of
the things that you could say is it
values relationships as semo says that
good relationships are to be foster are
to be preserved are
chosen the acid good over other goods
and their relationships are goods in the
you know in that they are intrinsic
goods themselves they're also
instrumental goods because in order for
a person to develop they have to develop
in relationships even if it comes down
to education I mean how many of you yeah
learn more under a professor who
connected with you and cared about you
as an individual he went to the office
hours if you talk with them how many of
you have gotten much more out of those
sorts of environments than out of a big
lecture hall
yeah that actually you know that brings
up another good point too when they're
together with other students we were in
same class classic classroom around a
team together before you like band you
know for example you're able to develop
those personal relationships as well and
we do know that students who study
together and talk together learn more
they acquire the world of good of
Education so relationships are not
something that get in the way
refer to the others who care other goods
they're actually what make other goods
more possible now does that mean that
every relationship is automatically good
and that would be one of the dangers of
this wouldn't abuse of relationships or
the ethics of care against a stay in the
abusive relationship after all it's a
relationship you know that a
relationship is good what what why would
I think some care saying you shouldn't
stay in abusive relationship
what makes it a piece of the
relationship
relationship and some people like it
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah something that would be in a
way that's sort of like the opposite of
a relationship is we call it a
relationship but abusive relationships
are really sort of one other thing I
want to get out to you before yeah the
same thing can be said about emotions we
talked about this one day before the
ethics of care values relationships it
also says that we we ought to cultivate
certain the attitudes or certain
emotions towards other people that
doesn't mean that that emotion by itself
is automatically a good so I get to be
as angry as I like to all the time and
say I'm an ethics of care person that
would really go against the idea nor
does it allow myself to sink into
depression there are going to be certain
balance
and what's going to allow you to
determine those criteria again it'll be
in terms of the growth the people
involved whether the motion sustained or
destroy relationships Canaan Druze great
relationships can anger also strengthen
a relationship I'll say about kids see
whether you can think of anything like
this in your history I ticked people off
the best when I was an issue when I was
around your age all the way through my
pranks people who have now good friends
with including my mentor I remember
kicking me out of his office because
being a jerk and somebody willing to
actually I was you know was really smart
so it's kind of on this a lot of things
that I bring into conversations hey you
tell I was just finishing and that
ticked it because you know he was he was
a guy with whole school kids he was
working on a degree of his own he was
teaching philosophy classes responsible
for all this stuff also owned a deacon
in a church and so really he didn't have
time for some you know 28 years six 27
year old kid to be spouting nonsense
you know big splash and stop so he told
me awful kicking out of his office that
made a big impression of what made the
impression on me wasn't the act so much
it was that it was aimed and I think
disappointed and I felt so bothered by
that that I realized I didn't make it
didn't make a huge difference right at
that time but I realized I needed to
change my personality be such a jerk
well that strengthened our relationship
there had to be a strong relationship
there to begin otherwise I'd be so after
get him I'll find somebody else to be my
mentor but the fact that he had a
relationship allowed that anger right
anger - he was technically right here to
see the situation you can see that to
produce a better effect for me into a
stronger relationship so anger can
sometimes
relationships the emotions that that the
ethics of cares to be most focused on
are in the sympathy sense of solidarity
with other people especially the most
vulnerable call care but the other
emotions so let me let me ask you since
we have just a few minutes left what do
you think of this this liked it dislike
it seemed like something you'd walk to
God or something you find troubling
okay what would either would you guys
you guys relate to that very do you have
stuff that you could take from this
class session yeah help you make better
moral decisions isn't just being told
that some of these things matter would
enable you to make better moral
decisions I feel like this theory is
very like self explint self-explanatory
it's like human nature that
relationships are good and your emotion
should matter but in this class we
haven't been told that that's what
matters now it's like oh that doesn't
matter I think it's kind of weird that
they do you have to like woman concerns
in it just like a random little like I
don't see why it has to be so specific
well historically again this might be
the generational difference historically
it took a feminist
saying hey this stuff matters for most
male philosophers to take that seriously
I don't know why that is because myself
I look at this and I'm like yeah that
sort of how did you put in something to
some explanatory it sort of follows from
itself
I don't think of myself as one and I see
these I think the way you do
yeah course relationships but yeah it's
what women like pushing really hard and
say these these things like mothering
are important to a relationship counts
I'm not sure why that should necessarily
be the case I guess it's just because
we're we're so he were so easily caught
up in our own perspective what are the
residue such a waste of time that could
be a legitimate answer this is this
useful for you yeah you like all that
stuff that we you know it's important to
us and that's that's natural that
sometimes we forget that those are
really the things that matter so it's
kind of it's more clearly feeling from -
if you die those are the things that
matter and to pay more attention under
respect okay that makes good sense
I forget exactly how much greater is the
sky pitch in China 20th century
philosophers so that velocities large
about reminding us
so maybe this is do you think this could
have an impact on somebody who doesn't
realize that that relationships are poor
are there people out there just don't
get that you're on touch with their own
emotions they can't stand other people's
emotions all right we'll be back there